when I first realized that we'd be
working on a stadium in Rome it was for
me a kind of coming full circle because
I'm often talked about sports
architecture in lectures by starting
with Colosseum
2,000 years later it's one of the most
important tourist attractions in Rome
and so even though it's not being used
in the way it was originally designed
it's still a viable building most of our
buildings the buildings I've designed
the buildings of other sports Architects
have designed they'll be gone designing
a new stadium that I knew a lot of
people are going to label is the new
Coliseum or you know the future of Rome
and that was pretty intimidating what we
think is modern today will look like it
was in the 80s 20 years from now but the
real idea about how you make a building
long-lasting in Rome is about the urban
nightmare you know I think there was a
big concern in all sports that the
better the broadcast got to be that more
difficult it was to get people to come
to the stadium the provocative statement
was the stadium is going to die it
cannot exist as well so then the
question is what will happen
the amazing experience of being together
with 70,000 people and watching
something happen I think that will
always be compelling to people and so
it's not just a stadium we've we've
wrapped it in a kind of la live again
learning from my staples history if you
can create a destination around the
stadium and make the event spill outside
and the ideas that fans would come there
and watch away game so they feel like
that's their home of their club that
they'll go there even when the clubs
playing summarize how do we make these
urban drivers for cities is really
something that I've been intrigued with
ever since we learned that lesson from
States so that's a really interesting I
did to the